herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
heute haben wir eine besondere neue
topmanager zwar von ich muss die
geschichte erzählen ich war letztens so
in den kommentar unterwegs besuchen wir
können wir wieder in change machen so
was raus und dann kommt beim run iaea
mit die sturm the challenge er sagt
kreeb den im bad auf und spielaufbau wie
70 alles klar
wollen junge freundin leichen und
seichten unterhaltung und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen runde
es ist ein ganz normaler tag ich bin
immer genau die gleiche person nicht
auch sonst mal bin und wir spielen hier
auf einem sehr gewohnten every für mich
denn ich bin offen offensichtlicher
weise leute man sieht partie
ich bin offensichtlich weise heuer wohl
bekannter und geschätzter und geliebter
war leider sieht man das nicht man dies
noch mal der typ der das verzockt hat
rania am ätna ganz ehrlich ich feiere
diese idee ab diesen kommentar gelesen
und dachte mir einfach so jopp das ist
es das ist es man dafür mache ich auf
jeden fall wieder einen job kriegt ja
wir müssen mal gucken wir uns hier so
schlagen auf fakt das war schon mal
nicht so gut das war schon mal nicht so
gut da müssen viel daraus wie würde ich
das kommentieren was das kann die ganze
verwirrung wird dadurch nur noch getoppt
dass ich einfach ingame claudia 1 1
können wir eine schweige sekunde dafür
haben dass ich in game einfach claudia 1
wer hat sich den nickname claudia 1 für
einen männlichen youtube einen wertigen
ländlichen youtube ausgedacht das ist
sehr sehr unpassend junge wird will die
checkpoints wie die wie stürmer für
mützen oder wie ich nützen wie ich
müssen eine sache noch vorneweg
natürlich habe ich persönlich nichts
gegen sturm diese gelegenheit war
einfach nur einmalig leute wie oft die
oft kommt dieser moment in eurem leben
vor dass euch zuschauer einfach eine
challenge in die kommentare schreiben
und ihre bedenken ob das ist es und
einfach wissen das ist machen müsst
einfach ich weiß nicht wie oft passiert
bei mir passiert nicht so oft deswegen
deswegen muss ich das heute machen an
alle hardcore sturm -fans unter meinen
zuschauern
nimm's nicht zu ernst und genießt
einfach mit mir wie ich heute heute
einfach den stimmigen skill auspacke
hier und jetzt können wir das schaffen
diesen sprung was bot wieso sind wir
dadurch gegen die wand genutzt man ich
verstehe das nicht ich kann dich drücken
mit diesen fv nicht springen und meine
meinung schlitz ist und er ist zur seite
verrutscht ich ersticke sie schlagen uns
wirklich gut
ich weiß nicht ob ihr schon mal mit fv
70 gespielt hat oder ob ihr schon mal zu
hause einfach nur so für euch und für
eure familie einfach mal sturm offen
nach gemacht hab ich gehe mal davon aus
dass ihr das kennt das gefühl
deswegen erzähle ich euch jetzt nichts
neues wenn ich sage dass es einfach sehr
ungewohnt ist mit einem watt mit einem
vollbart auf der b70 mai kräftig zu
spielen jawohl leute und da kommt direkt
das nächste windows modul alter schwede
es läuft es läuft sehr national es nicht
vorwärts
darunter fallen waren da hat gibt mir
macht es gibt mir dzemski gibt mir kraft
und gibt mir keine tram face mit die
schwöre euch auf den v70 entscheidet
minecraft einfach zufällig ob ihr einen
sprung schafft oder nicht
es hängt nicht davon ab wo er abspringt
das hängt nicht davon ab wie viel
schwung gehabt auf v70 entscheidet muss
einfach zufällig wir haben leider keinen
queenstown müssen zählt einfach so
durchschlagen und der erste final four
70 wo wir landen die fürstin wir wollen
wir raten wir sind sehr gut und ich sehe
nichts ich selig durch die haare
nein wir müssen die runde natürlich
gewinner die bei jeder anständigen
challenge geht es auch hier um den sieg
jaja können wieder ausschlagen könnte
mit auf stammen
du hast locker nicht so viele leben
junger jawohl wir haben in der tat gibt
mir kraft gespürt
wo kommen wir her wo kriegen wir einen
verfinstert eurotopics on demand finster
nein noch ein eisen warum soll ich ein
ernstes geführt dass es bisher ernst
jetzt wird's ernst
jetzt packen wir können machen
verizon stieg venture fragen ja ja
kannst du mir die ausleihe kriegst sie
auch zurück den youtube bin
juni ob wenn wir das läuft angeblich ist
da hinten
hier war er macht die macht ich glaube
gibt mir wirklich die workbench alter
wie du bist ein gott auf erden einfach
danke schön junge geil und jetzt du
kriegst du auch zurück ins dorf zurück
hier sagt dass er bald wieder okay wir
holen uns zuerst den ja er hat die
vollen acht tristans punkte wir haben
sechseinhalb come on come on kommt
kämpfen ich nicht weglaufen
jetzt wird der fall jetzt gefasst und
erleidet erleidet richtig sei sehr
schnell down alter und jetzt geht war da
hier komm und sag mal eisenstadt widmen
wir holen uns sind jetzt ich leute ich
spüre dass ich spüre die macht die die
macht in die mütze gibt mir kraft meinen
kleinen gesichtsbehaarung gebt mir
einfach kraft das als aber jetzt
aufhören
ich höre dann habe ich grauen region wir
haben gesagt worden
du hast das wüssten warum hat er mich
jetzt ab gestoppt werden nein jetzt hole
ich nicht dafür so okay jetzt haben wir
ihn jetzt gibt es hier einiges dafür
mich denkst du kannst dich abstauben
weißt du genau die möchte ich nicht bin
weißt du das überhaupt fragte mich nehme
ich kenne ich will nicht gehen
alles klar ok jetzt stellen die mitte
schaffen wir das rechtzeitig 20 sekunden
schnell in die mitte und mein gott
70 mitte zählt nicht sich mit dieter
zeit nicht sieht die hütte zählten
interessiert interessiert mich bisher
nicht bestätigt ist bisher nicht
passiert ist das hier nicht wie gewinne
ich höre was schreibt er da ich leike
dein video du verrückter kopf alter
schwede leute danke an alle die sich das
video bis hierhin durch geschehen
ich war ein sehr schlechter sturm war
glaube ich aber ich hab diesen kommentar
einfach gesehen und ich wusste dass ich
machen musste und es war ein sehr
energisch finale
wir haben alle unsere kraft
reingeschmissen ich habe zu viel über
bertl geredet ich weiß aber
dankeschönfest zuschauen und changes in
die kommentare
bis dann